[Music]
helen is in Boston
hi Helen how are you I'm good sir how
are you better than I deserve how can I
help
okay here's the doozy for you thank you
so much for taking my call by the way
I'm a military spouse the retiree mother
of five about to get a divorce after 20
years I am still waiting on the order
for child support I just got my third
job to make ends meet I start that in
September I am drowning to say the least
with the five kids eating me out of
house and home
your five kids at home yes sir after 20
years of marriage yes sir Oh 8 10 14 19
and 25 why is the 25 year old at home
because I'm trying to kick that one to
the military the 19 year old already
went and came back he's a paralegal in
the Army Reserves so the 25 year old
he's you know pain is share and I'm
trying to get that one to grow up that's
right so you have three kids and you
have Toledo one yeah and you have two
adults yes sir and so they can take care
of themselves if they have to help that
helps with the drowning okay yes sir
well we currently live on military
housing and because my husband's a
retiree he just moved out last month now
I have about a hundred and three
thousand dollars and dead 70,000 the see
I'm sorry 66 is with the student loans
eleven seven 11700 is with a car that my
husband has been paying for that now I'm
pretty sure I'm going to have to take
over and it has two more years of
payments I have a credit card debt of 25
thousand and my lawyers fees are three
thousand and growing and I've already
given this guy like $8,000 of course I
had to put it on a credit card because I
don't have any money now I'm doing my
best
to work that's why I got three jobs
you've been married 20 years how old are
you
I'm 45 when did he move out last month
three weeks ago three weeks ago and the
child support is I barely got $300 two
weeks ago so it's my turn to pay the
ransom timer first I have no idea how
it's going to come about but through the
grace of God how he's been getting me
through all this I'm a nurse and I know
that if you have if your nurse and you
have an income how come you can't pay
the rent I've never paid the rent my
husband has always paid it and I just
became a nurse two years ago trying to
pay off my dad work as a nurse yes sir
okay let's stop that okay the very that
when you're in a in a in a mess
financially what you do is you take care
of what we call the you protect the four
walls of your household before you do
anything so here's your here's your
order of priorities and you have enough
money to do these four things okay
you're going to take care of food first
yes sir you eat the kids eat period you
don't need out nobody in this house has
a resume eat out okay you are not
writing any checks at all for this 19
year old of this 25 year old yes they
bring money to the table or they move
out right they don't have a choice their
dad left yeah you can't support them
because you have a responsibility to the
minor children okay okay so food is
first lights and water second you are
the money to do those two things rent is
third you have the money to do all four
all three of those things and then you
keep lights and you keep gas in the car
is there another car one he just what
there's one vehicle one he has his own
car yeah well you're getting it you're
married so we have a car
care whose names on it is that car paid
for its got two more years and it also
got eleven thousand so less one your
sense well you said you got stuck with
what's the other car no the other ones
paid off his is paid off - wanna when he
bought four okay the one for our family
that he bought is the 11700 he didn't
find nothing we bought it we are married
legally yes attorney needs to explain
that to him he doesn't get to choose
this you get to choose this you're the
one with kids coming out your ears right
currently what the order was was for him
to pay seventy two percent and myself
twenty eight percent okay and that was
just two months ago so I then pay it
yeah the name needs to pay it has it
been paying it right no okay I don't
have your attorney put him in jail for
contempt of court
contempt yep that was the next one yeah
immediately because he's not supporting
his family you know you do not get to
just walk off legally in this country
not when you have an income okay so yeah
that's the attorneys job is to get this
money coming in okay so the so we're
gonna pay that your portion of the car
payment or pay the car payment one of
the two and keep the gas in the car so
you can go to work if you just eat keep
lights on pay the rent and keep the car
afloat the rest of this stuff we'll get
to overtime right now you're in the
middle of twenty years worth of emotion
and you're in the middle of fear and
anger and all this stuff going on and
I'm very angry and all this stuff is
overwhelming and and so what I'm
teaching you to do is to concentrate on
the simple most important things and let
the other stuff sit on the Shelf for now
call them call the who's got $60,000 for
the student loan that you 20 years after
marriage yeah it's all in my name even
though we used it together you know
sometimes we needed years going for no
within 20 years the past 10,000 was a
Student PLUS loan for my son and the
rest is mine that you know I've used for
school and you know to buy groceries and
whatever I needed throughout because
we're military were always poor and he
was the only one working while I was
going to school oh god call the student
loan people and put those student loans
on hardship referral I actually am only
pain they have me on $20 a month and the
other ones $10 a month and the other
ones different you can make that yes
okay
so first all my bills are paid the first
time the first goal is just add red
water then the second goal is we'll
start to make some progress through
these debts as we go along
okay I'm gonna be okay I got it I got it
that's why I'm prepared for this you
know got it you you got this I can feel
it no you're tough you're just you just
got the crap knocked out of you and
you're just trying to your head spinning
and that's okay that's okay exam five
kids keeping me going and they are my
reason for living so I went every canary
I think you're gonna keep them going
probably the way it works that's you
know but listen these two older ones
that this is they just instantly grew up
they don't have a choice they did they
did ones looking for a paralegal job he
just came home after after his training
and the other one is it's just been a
little struggle bullshitting him there
he's 25
he's 25 I won't hear everybody's
struggle yeah I'll just have been
hearing about your struggle I don't want
to hear about him I want him dude man up
yeah well I get in the next 13 seconds
man up that's what he's got to do all
right it's time cuz mama's got enough
dealing not dealing with a baby that's
25
yes sir he went correct all right now
let's go stop doing with you concentrate
on the three little ones now here's what
we're gonna do you're you're making what
is a nurse let's see I just figured it
all out let's see with my full time job
I make fifty six thousand that's what I
want to be I don't want to talk about
that that's fine and then you can pick
up if you're gonna pick up extra jobs
pick them up as a nurse like in the ER
or something that's where you can make
the most money on your extra jobs if
you've got to do some extra stuff in the
meantime you can make this on fifty six
what you've given me here you're gonna
be okay hold on I'm gonna put you
through Financial Peace University I'll
put you in the one-year membership and
you can go through the class and and
take the 14 year old with you or the end
the 19 year old if you want I don't care
let's teach everybody in this house so
this is this never comes back to this
house again hold on tele I'll pick up
we'll get you signed up you're gonna
make it you got the stuff kiddo this is
the Dave Ramsey show